the trailers aren't stopping we now have
a new TV spot from the Super Bowl for
x-men apocalypse holy [ __ ] on this I
mean that [ __ ] on this as in bat [ __ ] on
this is anole [ __ ] trailer only showed
us a couple of new things and more of
stuff we already knew was gonna happen
it shows a lot of destruction of the
earth and I do mean destruction you kind
of wonder how much of this is visions
you know in the last trailer gene was
like I saw all this death and xavius
like gene it was just a dream I mean you
see nuclear warheads going up is that
part of the vision is that the dream
does does that actually happen you see
the earth literally looks like
everything is turning into sand and
getting blown away like dust I mean to
do is the biggest he's the baddest in
the last trailer they established that
really like they didn't come many names
over many lifetimes raah Krishna Yahweh
Stamos and I'm gonna take your planet
and [ __ ] it into the dirt I feel like
apocalypse he's just gonna walk out like
that dick from the crow he's gonna be
like ya got an impression for you gaga
bang [ __ ] dad oh the world you were
impersonating the world could you
quickly screwed it he looks like an
[ __ ] it's funny we've all seen the
force awakens now so we're like Poe
Dameron you're so likable
how are you at all that you really
screwing the world in this movie we get
a sweet shot a psylocke in this trailer
I'm not just saying that because of the
angle folks alright
be classy be classy salic was always one
of my favorites I don't know why she was
like the ex crush that I had when I was
a kid that Psylocke knife was business
man cut that car in half that she was
red it was long I just got really
excited when watching this which is
funny I do understand now the gripe that
people had about Wolverine in the last I
guess phase of the x-men movie you know
Wolverine was like the main character
and old-school
x-men fans were like Wolverines not
supposed to be the main characters not
making them the main character now it
seems like Jennifer Lawrence still like
hey why don't we just you know put
Katniss and everything so now mystique
Raven who wasn't really all Katniss ish
in x-men first class is now like I'm
here to fight war and fight and I just
hear Katniss Everdeen talking and I
can't help it so we'll see how that goes
in my mind's eye when I watch the movie
so the x-men apocalypse Super Bowl
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]